[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to the
Data Science Hangout.
Hope you're all
having a great week.
I'm Rachael Dempsey,
if we haven't
had a chance to meet yet.
I lead our pro
community at Posit.
And so the Data Science Hangout,
if you've never been before,
is our open space to
chat about data science
leadership, questions
you're facing, and getting
to hear about what's going
on in the world of data
across different industries.
And so it happens every
Thursday at the same exact time,
same place.
So if you're watching
this recording sometime
in the future, on
YouTube later, the link
to add it to your calendar
will be in the details below.
And we'd love to have
you join us live, too.
Together, we're all
dedicated to making
this Hangout a welcoming
environment for everybody,
and so we love hearing from
everyone no matter your level
of experience or area of work.
It's totally OK to
just listen in here,
and there's always
three ways you
can jump in and ask questions
or provide your own perspective,
too.
So you can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And feel free to put a
little star next to it
if you want me to
read it instead--
if you're in a coffee shop
or kids are running around
or whatever is going on.
And then third, we
also have a Slido link
where you can ask
questions anonymously,
and I see Hannah just shared
that in the chat right now,
so thanks, Hannah.
I will say, Emily, I have
wanted you to join us here
for so long, and we
have also had a number
of requests to have you on.
So I'm so excited to have
you here with us today.
Emily is Senior Manager,
Customer Management,
Data Science and
Analytics at Capital One.
Now, Emily, let's
maybe get started
by just having introduce a
little bit about your role
and what you do and
maybe something you
like to do outside of work, too.
Yeah, definitely.
And thank you so much, Rachael.
Thrilled to be here.
I've benefited so much,
like, listening and watching
the videos from all
these conversations.
And really excited
to take part today.
So I've been at Capital One
for about the past seven years.
Over that time, I've held a
number of different roles.
But fortunately, both
the data science toolbox
and, specifically, R has really
been a through line for me
throughout whatever
I've been doing.
Spent some time on the
more strategic analytics
and modeling spaces, solving
very specific business problems
related to our card business.
I'd say, overall, I think
my career has pulled me
kind of progressively further
and further up the data stack,
as no matter what problem
downstream I'm really motivated
by solving, I always realize
there's some roadblock just one
level higher, and I get
really excited about, well,
how do I just solve
that one pain point?
And that one, I'll unlock.
So, after starting out more in
that first-line data science
space, moved a little
bit further upstream
when I got really
passionate about InnerSource
tooling and bringing the best
of what I saw from the outside
our community into my company
and building internal packages
to help us solve common
business problems,
like customer lifetime
value modeling,
setting and forecasting
KPIs, and even connecting
to different enterprise systems.
And really enjoyed kind
of like building out
both those packages,
but also really
figuring out that you needed to
also build out an inner source
community around them, again
copying so much from what I've
learned from #rstats
Twitter, and then
kind of continuing that
trajectory upstream.
Moved more and
more progressively
into also adding in elements of
analytics engineering and data
engineering to
tackle standardizing,
harmonizing, breaking silos
in that raw data input that
would then flow through the
tools and the ultimate data
products.
So that's kind of my trajectory
and where I've landed today.
Awesome.
And what's something you like
to do outside of work, too?
Big, big runner
and big reader.
Nice.
We'll have to ask you about some
favorite books later on, too.
But I love that you
just started off
with talking about
InnerSource there,
and that's something that
actually came up on a Hangout--
maybe that was last year, was
Zac Garland at Mastercard.
And I'm curious, for
all of us here, too,
what does InnerSource
really mean?
And can you explain a bit
about what that community
looks like at Capital One?
Yeah, definitely.
So in some ways, it's
almost a funny thing
to explain because I think
to the Open Source Community,
it sounds so natural,
it's almost like,
why does this concept
require its own name?
But I think sometimes
in large corporations
or just in different
environments,
you don't just have
that nice synergy where
someone sitting
halfway in the world
as you has happened to
already solved your problem
and put the answer up on GitHub.
And so there can be
a lot of, I think,
redundant work, both in
one person's project--
like moving from
project to project--
or different teams solving
very similar problems--
maybe sometimes
reinventing the wheel
on even the framework for
solving that problems,
other times using the
exact same framework
but rewriting the
same boilerplate code,
like for hyperparameter
tuning, or something like that.
So InnerSource is
just really the idea
of both building tools
and an internal code base
that multiple teams can
contribute to over time.
And, as I mentioned,
that only also
works if you try to build up
that same sort of community,
and enthusiasm, and inclusivity,
and knowledge sharing around it
to support it.
And so that's with a lot
of the internal packages
that you create too?
Yeah, definitely.
So, yeah, a lot of--
I think you can think about the
definition pretty expansively,
being anything from--
I mean, there's so
many opportunities
I think to standardize
across the data stack.
But I think the place I've
definitely focused on it most
is in the R package space.
I love that.
So, hopefully, one package
for one thing, and then
everybody across Capital
One is using it for that?
Yeah.
That's always been the goal.
And I think the other
really cool thing
about that is really digging
into the levels of abstraction
and that not--
you, obviously, never want
to constrict different teams
from like solving
problems in different ways
because different
parts of the business
inherently should be
customizing and tailoring.
But it becomes a really
fun problem thinking
what should be standardized.
Like, not everyone wants
to write the glue code
to connect to database and
get through your proxy.
But where are the right
degrees of freedom
of what optimization method
might be truly better for one
type of problem than another?
And then it also,
I think, helps you
aggregate those
business-use cases
and create that kind of
body of knowledge of these
are how different teams have
solved this different problems,
why they needed to layer
in different tools.
And it becomes kind
of a knowledge store,
I think, for some of the
complexity of any given
problem.
I'm always really
interested in how
you can standardize
across standardized things
but also share new
packages or share
ways of doing things across
such a huge company, too.
Yeah, no, I mean,
I think definitely--
as best you can, I
think a lot of companies
do use a version control
system, like GitLab or GitHub.
So obviously, first
step minimum bar
is just getting it out there.
But I think there's a
great little O'Reiley
book on InnerSource that
one of the chapter headlines
is literally, like, just because
you use GitHub doesn't mean
you're doing InnerSource,
which I think
is really critical that
I think in open source,
we are sometimes spoiled by the
extent to which it is if you
build it, they will come.
They will not always
come internally.
I think corporate
incentives are different.
Sometimes, the
culture people just
have no expectation
that if they look,
they might find something.
So I think, definitely, there's
a little bit more shoe leather
beat the pavement in terms
of talking to other teams,
trying to go present
it in internal forums.
But also, again, building up
that community with things
like--
I leaned very heavily on Slack
channels to kind of bootstrap
an internal version
of Twitter to try
to get those just serendipitous,
async conversations going.
Yeah, definitely.
Libby, I see you had asked
something in the chat
a bit earlier.
Do you want to jump in?
Sure, yeah.
I was wondering if you could
describe in general terms,
without giving a bunch of
details that you can't give,
maybe some of the
projects or the problems
that you are working on solving
with your team right now?
Yeah, definitely.
So I think pretty
wide range of things,
and I'm trying to figure
out how to answer that,
to be perfectly honest, at the
right level of abstraction.
But I think something that's
really been top of mind
for me lately is just how you
can really shape that raw data
layer and make it the most
usable for the [INAUDIBLE]
last mile analysis.
So one broad area of
interest that I'll say
has been really on
my mind is thinking
about how to structure raw
data into really meaningful--
you could almost call it like
a metric SMART or feature MART,
although it's not
quite the same thing.
But just how you can embed
more context about a business
problem in individual
data elements
to have more of those off the
shelf for use kind of across--
metrics tracking across modeling
and feature engineering.
Some of the business areas
that I'm most focused
on these days in our code
space is our [INAUDIBLE]
to practice
strategies to help be
sure we're equipping our
customers to have the best
both financial
health but ability
to pursue their interests.
Thank you.
I'm starting to see a lot of
questions over in the chat,
too.
And, Mike, I swear I did
not see your question there
when I asked that,
so maybe I'm starting
to think a data science
leader a little bit more here.
But, Mike, did you have any
follow-up questions or anything
else you want to get
out of communicating
InnerSource packages
and best practices?
Yeah, thanks.
I mean, first of all,
it's great having Emily
on this Data Science thing.
I've been following your
blog posts for ages,
and they're really
inspirational.
So please keep doing those.
The question was
really about what
I see a lot is that when
you send out an email,
or send out a message on
Teams, or have a community
meeting, maybe you only get
20% of the whole population
of people you're trying to
target at that one thing.
And there's value in spamming
people across many platforms,
but I also know that many
of the people that I want
to try and target with
here's a best practice,
or I've written this
document, or here's
a package you might be
interested in, some of them
have already kind of muted
that channel or an email
rule that just, I'll chuck
about straight into this folder.
So how do you gradually
increment the number of people
who see those messages?
Yeah.
I think, definitely, in
an enterprise setting,
I think I have also learned
more also on those personal
relationships to get the word
out than you would necessarily
in the open-source context--
so both in terms of I
think leaning on leadership
to help identify people that may
be working on similar projects
or patterns throughout
the company.
Or, ideally, I think
having a forum where you're
intended to share updates
not on an individual project
because it's like, how
do you get people to come
to that forum initially?
But if you can get people
interested in the idea
of technical knowledge
sharing at a higher level,
aggregating many types of
information in that one space,
again, to make an open-source
analogy that kind of internal R
open Ci analog or internal--
R weekly-type
newsletter, I think
it can be easier to
sell and socialize
the broader concept than maybe
an individual artifact thereof.
Yeah, thanks.
Thank you.
Marlene I see you had
a question in the chat.
Do you want to jump in here?
Yeah, sure.
Hey, Emily.
By the way, great
presentation at [INAUDIBLE]..
That was where I first got to
see you, so that was fantastic.
And my question was, what
do you do in your job
that you didn't actually
anticipate see yourself doing?
I think we all kind of get
blindsided by this weird niche
skill or task, and we're like, I
didn't sign up for this, right?
But I was just
curious because you've
been the Capital One
for a bit, do you
have anything like
that you could share?
Oh, my god.
If anything, I feel
like that's truly
the story of--
and to your point,
I don't think I'm
unique in this regard,
but I think does almost feel
like it summarizes my career
arc.
Went from math to
statistics because I
wanted to do math
through the real world,
but then found the shift
from like deductive
to inductive reasoning
not at all like math.
Then went from stats
to data science
because I wanted to use the
statistical toolbox to solve
these beautiful,
probabilistic-type problems,
but then found all
of my challenges
were more like data
and tooling layer.
And so, I mean, I think it's--
this may be a kind
of generic answer,
but I think being obsessed
with not only data quality but,
even upstream of that, how
is data getting collected?
How do the source
systems work that are
processing the
customer records that
are then spitting out the data?
I think I definitely
never expected
myself to keep going further
upstream and further back
into more of the
technical stack as opposed
to proving a nice
little theorem, which
is where I started out.
But I think definitely
something where
I think a lot of
my mind share goes
but that I find is super
helpful for the last mile
because even if some really
weird quirk in your system
of like, oh, we were
never able to email
these customers for x reasons,
it's, suddenly, then you
also know population,
that something happened to
for a systemic reason that could
fuel some really interesting
analysis.
So I think the both
going upstream but then
being able to roundtrip
back downstream
are probably two things that I
never would have anticipated.
Yeah, cool.
It's funny you share that.
I recently was told that
Data Science were snobs.
Like, we're only happy with the
tail end of the data stream.
I quickly had to
snap my head around
and say, well, I think
we're, if anything, more
holistically-- we're interested
in the holistic health of data
from start to finish, literally
nurturing it from its inception
all the way to the end.
But I found that
really interesting.
So it's funny that
you're reiterating that,
that you find yourself looking
downstream just as much
as you are upstream
and where you're at.
Anyway, thanks for sharing.
I'll shut up now.
Not at all.
And, yeah, I love that.
I mean, to me, I
think that's also
part of what really puts
the science in data science,
is seeing the whole system.
I forget-- someone
in the "college-y"
side of our stats Twitter once
commented on something I wrote
about, oh, like, the
data-generating process--
I have all these same
concerns as you do.
It just, for me, it's
when I fell out of a boat,
and I dropped my notepad.
And it's very different
cause of missing data
but potentially similar outcome.
I love that, putting the
science in data science.
[LAUGHS] Alan, I see you had
a question in the chat, too.
Want to jump in next?
Yeah, sure.
Hi, Emily.
I'm really curious to
learn a little bit more
about where your team fits in,
if there's a bigger analytics
organization in which you fit.
And do you have peers who are
similar leaders of analytics
within other
functions and teams?
And if you collaborate, and
what that expectation is,
or if your focus is mostly
kind of inward to your team?
And I know it's probably
a mix of all of the above.
I'm just really curious
in how your team fits
in the rest of an organization
that I imagine is really big.
Yeah.
No, and I'll definitely again
dance around that potentially a
tiny bit, just to not talk
to too much about Capital One
specifics.
ALAN SCHUSSMAN: Sure, sure.
But, yeah, super large
organization, very matrixed.
I've always sat within a
specific line of business
and been predominantly focused
on solving that business's
problems.
I was pretty lucky to have super
supportive leadership, I think,
early on and continuing
throughout my career that
really kind of latched on
to a lot of these same ideas
of abstraction and scale and
was willing to kind of support
building out a team that
honestly is a little bit
more business facing and
interdisciplinary skill
sets than would usually
even be tackling
some of these problems versus
kind of with your tech team
or data engineering team or
breaking all those pieces up.
But, yeah, we definitely have a
lot of great kind of, I think,
analogs throughout
the business that
have their teams
structured, really,
in many different ways--
like, the mix of
staffing, whether it
be more business-focused people
or engineering-focused people,
or whether it be like
centralized or federated.
And it can definitely
be complex navigating
a really large org in that way.
But I think it does help bring
a lot of interesting ideas
to the table when you have
different types of people
and different org configurations
all trying to tackle problems,
bring the best spare
of their own tool deck.
For sure, yeah.
And your journey
sounds like it's
been one of building that
really focused team in part.
Yeah, definitely.
And I think, based on, I
think, the biggest bet,
that the people
that were maybe--
I mean, like me, starting out
a little bit more downstream,
maybe not the best
state-- like, not
the best engineer by a mile
that you could put on that work,
that finding people that can
bridge those multiple worlds
and pull that downstream
context upstream, I think
is maybe not what I'd say
is the overarching norm,
but I think is
definitely a pattern that
is getting some good traction.
Cool, thank you.
EMILY RIEDERER: Thank you.
I see Javier is calling out
your amazing book collection
behind you.
And so Javier said it looks
like data science book heaven.
Do you have a favorite
book behind you?
Oh, my goodness.
That would be a
hard one to pick,
and we could use the rest of
the hour going through those.
One of my weirdest or
strangest post-pandemic hobbies
has been I had the
opportunity to review
a ton of books for CRC Press,
and then, as a consequence,
have built out my library
with a lot of those.
I think, off the top
of my mind, obviously,
[INAUDIBLE] Rethinking
Statistics I know is a little
bit of a generic recommendation,
but I think can just be such
a lovely--
whether or not
you're [INAUDIBLE]..
Won't get controversial
here, but it's just
such a beautiful
probabilistic approach
to thinking about
data and modeling.
I have a lot of
epidemiology books,
just because I but never was
really in the health sciences
field myself, but I
found those to actually
be some of the most informative,
strangely, for business use
because I think stats
books often talk
about things from the
standpoint of like,
assume you have this
perfectly clean data.
It's in this matrix called x.
Now we'll prove
some nice theorems.
Whereas epi books almost
start more with like,
[INAUDIBLE] fire.
We want to figure something out.
We don't have any
of the data we want.
There are biases everywhere.
What do we do given that.
And I think like,
again, when you're just
trying to work with a lot
of larger observational data
in an org setting, that's
just super pragmatic.
What can I do with what I have
available, is pretty cool.
But again, could definitely pass
along a lot more specific recs
based on the category.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: What was the
title of the first one you
recommended?
EMILY RIEDERER: I may
have said it wrong.
I think it's actually
Statistical Rethinking.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
OK, If anybody wants
to share the link
to that in the chat,
that would be
super helpful, too.
But Emily, something
I wanted to ask you
is, I know so many people
here in our Hangout room
have benefited from your
blogs, and conference talks,
and so much more.
And I was just
wondering, for you,
what have been some of the
benefits of contributing
to the open source community?
EMILY RIEDERER: Oh my
goodness, like so very many.
I think first and
foremost, obviously,
it's just all of the amazing
relationships you form,
people you get to
meet, and being
a fly on the wall
of conversations
that I'd never get to
hear-- like epi professors
talk, or bio stats professors
talk, or econ professors
talk in my day-to-day life.
But just being able
to continue to pull--
and I think this is
especially unique
to ours from all these
really rich interdisciplinary
communities and
steal the best ideas,
and then take them
back to my day job.
And then I look like I came up
with a new idea, and I didn't.
I'm just feeling like an artist.
So I think that the people
is definitely a huge benefit.
In terms of contributions,
I think something
that I found a very
surprising benefit is
the way that it's made me
have to think a lot more
critically and a lot more
formally about what I was doing
anyway and otherwise.
I think even as I've dodged
a couple of questions
here today of, oh,
how much detail can I
go into here, the
upside of that is,
I think, a lot of the things
that I've found that I can
really lean in to talk
about, it forces me to think
about the problems that
I'm facing at that higher
level of abstraction
and think about what,
have I learned from
this that's not
just true to my last project,
but it's my next project,
and it's true to other
people's projects?
So I think it's definitely a
fun intellectual challenge,
I think almost like taking
a final exam in school,
to force you to formalize
your own knowledge.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: That's
really interesting, yeah.
So by not being able to
give some of the specifics,
you're able to then take
a step back and look
at this big picture,
so that it can then
help other people, too.
EMILY RIEDERER: Think
a little bit more
in terms of those,
like, core patterns.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Definitely.
I see-- apologies if I
mispronounce your name.
I'm not sure if your first
and last are connected there.
But Hebah Bukhari, you had
a question into the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
HEBAH BUKHARI: Hey, Rachael.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Hi.
HEBAH BUKHARI: That
was close enough.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Hebah?
HEBAH BUKHARI: Yeah.
Hi, Emily.
Very nice to meet you.
And yeah, great talk.
I love your blog.
And I was wondering,
for someone who
is making the transition
into the data science world
and trying to build her
portfolio and her skills,
I think from what
I'm seeing is more
important than the experience
is showing off the skills,
and showing off
the personal brand.
So what advice would
you have for someone
who is like, I'm still
building my blog,
I'm still trying to create
stuff to be able to put them out
there?
What advice would you have
for me or someone like me?
EMILY RIEDERER: Yeah, no
great, great question.
And I think--
I'm trying to remember.
I think it was back
in 2018 or 2017.
It's been a while.
But David Robinson
gave an amazing talk
at our studio
conference about this
that's probably floating
around in a video
somewhere that I
know I personally
found really empowering.
I think the first and
foremost advice, I think,
is get it out there.
Anything that's out
in the world, I think,
was really the
thesis of his talk,
is better than anything
that's on your hard drive.
And I think that can at
times be intimidating.
But I think, a, I
think a lot of work
can be a lot more
impressive and interesting
to the outside world
than sometimes we
even believe when
we've been mile deep
working on it for so long.
And also, especially in a great
community like the ERstats
community, I feel
like people are
really supportive that,
yeah, they might have
some advice or other ideas.
So maybe they leave a comment.
But everyone does it in
such a genuinely nice way,
if anything, sometimes
I crave for somebody
to comment on something
that I wrote and be like,
no, you're wrong, and
here's 10 reasons why,
because I think that'd be a
really interesting discussion.
But I think, A, definitely
don't be intimidated
to get stuff out there.
And then, I think the
second key thing is, again,
finding projects that you're
like genuinely interested in
and passionate by.
I think a lot of people--
there's decreasing
marginal returns
from an employer's
perspective seeing someone
else play with the
Titanic data set,
whereas like I think
you'll showcase
your own skills better, as well
as really engage your audience,
if you just chase
after some passion
and find something a little
bit new and different to bring
to the table.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Thank you.
I think I missed one of your
questions from earlier, Travis,
and I just want to
have you jump in here.
Sorry about that.
TRAVIS GERKE: Yeah, no worries.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I think that
maybe it was a while ago.
TRAVIS GERKE: Yeah,
no, it's fine.
Hey, Emily, sorry to break
your level of abstraction
that you've built up here.
But I wanted to ask
a bit about DPT.
I know we talked about
this a couple of years ago.
TRAVIS GERKE: I wonder how
that's evolved for you.
Are you using it
still these days?
Have you integrated more with R?
You have the DPT
Flyer package, which I
see is just hanging out there.
Trying to generate interest
across the community--
it's a really cool
complementary tool,
but not a lot of integrations
yet as far as I can tell.
How's it going for you?
EMILY RIEDERER:
Yeah, no, I'm still--
and maybe I'll just take
a step back and explain
for a minute what dbt is for
those that aren't familiar.
dbt is a framework for
building data pipelines in SQL.
And what it gets you is a
lot of the same benefits
that I think we all value
with reproducibility
in R, which tends to be harder
with databases and with dbt.
So you can do things
like devprod deployments.
You can do better testing.
It helps you modulize
your code better
so you can have easier version
control, easier code reviews.
And it just ends with some
[INAUDIBLE] templating.
It makes SQL more like
a higher-level kind
of programming language with
a legitimate control flow.
Definitely, if you
work on databases,
I'd recommend checking it out.
I think there's a lot of
spiritual similarity with just
things this community tends
to value and get excited by.
I continue to be a big
fan of using both tools.
I'd have to say, I've
never really found
that sweet spot of exactly
learning how to integrate them.
I think I still tend to have
dbt pipelines joining more
into the Database
Player, but kind
of switching more
into R mode for real,
obviously, [INAUDIBLE] analysis,
reporting, modeling, et cetera.
I've always felt like there had
to be some linkage, especially
with something like dbflyer,
but have not gone there yet,
and would be
fascinated if anyone
else has played with both
and has any takes there.
TRAVIS GERKE: Yeah, likewise.
In all your spare time, right?
[LAUGHS] And I'm sure everyone
else is in the same space.
But yeah, my experience
has been the same.
I feel like when I'm in dvtm,
it's straight SQL world,
and there's no direct linkage.
But mirroring your thoughts
on the spiritual similarity.
The community there is
really, really good,
and it's a good tool if
you want to check it out.
EMILY RIEDERER: Yeah,
and at minimum, it's
like it helps kind of keep
your mind in the same place,
even if there's not quite
that deep, deep integration.
TRAVIS GERKE: Yeah, thanks.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
Sounds like this
would be a good part to share
with the Tidyverse team, too.
EMILY RIEDERER: Yeah,
let's [INAUDIBLE]..
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
[LAUGHS] So I see--
so I just want to
remind everybody,
if you joined a
little bit later,
that you can ask questions
a few different ways.
So there's a Slido
link if you want
to ask anything anonymously.
You can always raise
your hand here on Zoom.
Or, you can continue
putting questions
into the Zoom chat too.
And if you put a
little star next to it,
I'll know to read it out loud.
But I see [INAUDIBLE]
had asked, piggybacking
on Libby and Mylene's earlier
questions, what has kept you
at Capital One for seven years?
EMILY RIEDERER: That's
a great question.
I know especially
in this day and age,
I think it's the
less common route
to stay at a single
company for a long time.
I think there's definite, I
think, pros and cons to it.
I think definitely, the thing
that's kept me motivated
is being able to continue
to expand my scope,
expand my skill set, both in
terms of such a large company
having different areas of
business to move around too--
which is, so I'm still thinking
about different strategic
issues throughout
my career, somewhat
similar to changing companies,
as well as growing out
my technical skills in
different dimensions.
So I think I'm
definitely somebody
that gets very edgy if I
don't feel like I'm continuing
to learn, but I
think I've found ways
that I really feel
like I continue to be
able to do that in my career.
And secondly-- this is
a very silly reason,
definitely not a
career-defining one--
but going back to [INAUDIBLE]
source, I will warn you,
packages are kind
of like children,
and there have been
times in my career,
even, where I've been
offered a different role
internally or something,
and I've been like,
oh, but then I'm just like, I
don't know how to say goodbye.
So be warned.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
[LAUGHS] Thank you.
Trevor, I see you had
a question in the chat.
You want to jump in next?
TREVOR: Hi, everyone.
Good day.
Yeah, so I've been following
this space very carefully,
and I've been a part of several
discussions about the impact
that AI is and will
have on our profession.
I must say I'm just uncertain
about the future, to be honest.
It's developing and
evolving so fast,
so I was just
trying to understand
from your perspective, what
do you see how AI is actually
impacting your current workflow,
and what your thoughts are
in terms of how it would impact
data science space in the mid
to--
well, near to mid future?
EMILY RIEDERER: Yeah, no, that
is such an interesting issue
right now.
And I feel like definitely,
I know a lot of very strongly
opinionated-- strong
opinions on both sides
of the spectrum of whether
it's going to change everything
or nothing.
I think through the
type of work I do,
and the type of values, per se,
that I have about data science,
I think there are
large parts of it
that I don't expect
it to change a ton,
or I almost hope it
doesn't change a ton.
And I'll give a couple
of examples of that.
I know I think,
even, there are a lot
of companies and
tools right now that
are working on automated
NLP query generation--
which, on one hand,
seems really cool.
Yeah, I'd love to be able to
just answer anyone question,
ask a question
and get an answer.
But then, there's, I think, the
data quality part in my head.
It's like the fire
alarm goes off.
That, there may be an AI that's
like smart enough to write
a sonnet far sooner than there
is one that's smart enough
to think, based on the kind of
conditional probability this
person allotted, should I cast
the nulls in this table to a 0,
or should I leave them as 0's?
And what should be
in the denominator?
And I mean, I think, if
anything, data quality and data
bias will save us, because I
think those are so sufficiently
hard for humans to
ever be precise enough
in language about
what they mean,
and clear enough on what
the right result should be,
that I feel pretty
confident that's
going to remain a solidly human
problem for a much longer time.
And then, similarly, on the last
mile, like I mentioned before,
I think I'm very passionate
about thinking about feature
engineering, curating
both automated solutions,
but also understanding,
and bringing context
in to data science--
whether you even think about
cost-sensitive loss functions,
model evaluation beyond
traditional metrics.
And I could imagine
more guesswork shifting
to those first mile and
last mile of data quality,
and duration, and rigorous
business-focused evaluation,
but I definitely
don't expect our jobs
to go away because of AI.
TREVOR: I understand
what you're saying,
but even a lot of the
processes that you talk about,
we see AI making its
way into that space.
I understand, and I do
totally agree with your point
about, for example,
the feeding of data.
An AI system may
not know the context
of what a missing value should
be or why a piece of data
is missing.
But my thought process is a
little broader in the sense
that, for example, as
someone asked earlier,
what you should be
thinking about when
you're entering the data space?
As in, if you're in school now,
you are in, maybe, university,
you're in the middle of
doing a data science degree,
what does your future look like?
So we have seen, for example, in
the last, maybe, 5 to 10 years,
last five years,
we have seen where
data science is the hottest
topic and the hottest job.
Do we think that this
hot streak is going
to continue into the future?
Or will this hot streak
be replaced by AI,
if you understand
what I'm asking?
EMILY RIEDERER:
Yeah, definitely.
I mean, at the end
of the day, I think
they're probably all
just tools in the toolbox
to solve the super
wide range of problems.
I don't even know if
data science will always
be a career, so
much as data science
is an expectation of
something professionals
should be able to apply to the
problems they have at hand,
like manipulating an
Excel spreadsheet.
And similarly, with AI, I
think there are probably
some things, like
in a legal setting,
like parsing a ton of documents,
generating some hypotheses,
helping maybe structure
a preliminary screen
for legal discovery
or something.
I think there's some
kind of assistive things
AI can help with,
but I personally,
I think, don't love
the idea of a world
where it's ever making
the final decisions.
So I think plenty of space
at the table for both.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
Yeah, definitely.
TREVOR: OK.
All right, thanks.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Thank you.
I love that perspective
on it, and thinking
about how everybody knows
how to use Excel right now.
Maybe at some point
in the future,
everybody will know how to do
some level of data science.
I see, Jonathan, you had
asked a question on--
there's a star,
so I'll read it--
but it's, data science involves
tackling complex problems.
What is your thought
process to solving a problem
that you don't know how
to solve immediately?
What resources do you
into that assist you
with problem-solving?
EMILY RIEDERER: That's
a really good question
and a really, like,
pertinent question, lately, I
think, for a couple
of different reasons.
I think one thing that I think
is a really undervalued part
of that process is
thinking about what is--
how will a good solution
when you find fun one,
and how would you know
if it was a good solution
if it was staring you in the
face and you already had it?
I think the more
unstructured and complicated
a problem can be, it can almost
be a little deceptive of what's
good-- which can have one or two
bad outcomes of either you find
a good solution, but
you don't realize
it's good so you
keep going, or you
spend a lot of time
chasing after an outcome,
and then you get there, and
only then do you realize,
I solved the problem
I was trying to stop,
but not the problem
I wanted to solve.
So something I've really
been experimenting
with in my own work is having a
lot more of an explicit design
stage at the beginning of
a project and thinking,
how can you do a pilot?
How can you-- if I'm trying
to predict some target,
can I take those two
values of that target
and plug them into a
downstream problem I actually
thought that I was
going to solve,
and make sure that's actually
what I want to solve?
And almost like frontloading
model evaluation
with even fake solution,
is like the first step
versus last step.
And then, I'll check
on one other point.
And I'm rambling here, but
I think the other aspect
of that-- just, again,
going back to that levels
of abstraction--
is figuring out how to
take the context out
of my problem to make it
something more Googleable.
So I mean thinking,
not being like,
oh, this experiment, the
random seeds were wrong,
so I don't have a
control population.
What do I do?
But then, backing that
into more of a general,
like, how do you sample
a synthetic control
through observational data?
Which is something you
can Google and then
find a ton of resources about.
So I think pushing
myself on what I want,
and then finding the
right [INAUDIBLE]
at which to ask for help.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: That's
great, thank you.
Ahnas, I see you had a question.
Do you want to
jump in here next?
AHNAS ALZAHABI: Sure.
So Emily, I'm sure you've
been in this position before,
but any tips and
advice on communicating
to non-technical stakeholders
and/or leadership?
EMILY RIEDERER: Yeah, no,
that's always the hot--
enduring hot topic, and for
very, very good reasons,
I think.
I think a couple of
different, I think,
approaches that I tend
to use there is, A,
reading with the
solution versus--
leading with the
solution, and leading
with impact, versus leading
with that kind of process.
And I think, as
many people know,
I'm like huge Markdown fan--
and maybe now I
should say Quarto--
but I've actually come
to the realization
that I need to even change
my workflow for working
with a tool like that because
inherently, an Markdown
workflow is very linear--
like I cleaned my data,
I did the analysis,
I got the outcome.
But then, from a
storytelling perspective,
I think you can
really get the hook
and get the buy-in to keep that
conversation going if you lead
more with the outcome of, this
is why what I'm about to tell
you is important.
And then, some people
want to really dig deeper
and understand the mechanics.
Some people won't.
And I think it's also,
as a data person,
they need to accept that that's
OK, but they don't want to.
I think all of us,
it's like it can really
be about the journey
versus the outcome,
but accepting for like
leaders, reasonably,
it is often about the outcome.
But then, when I want to
go into those details,
I think I both either
try to lean heavily
on both and/or either of
metaphors and also diagrams,
or one really compelling plot--
just anything to
make it more tangible
versus purely conceptual.
AHNAS ALZAHABI: Thank you.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
Thank you very much.
I see, Louis, you had a
similar question as well.
And do you have any
follow-up questions,
or does that answer you as well?
LOUIS BOGUCHWAL: I
guess maybe a follow-up,
and maybe it really is the same.
Just to clarify, just
that, in one sense,
makes it sound a
communication kind of piece.
But do you have the
same answer if it's
a brand new project, or maybe a
completely different approach?
I don't mean a new
quantitative approach,
but maybe, here's
a stakeholder who's
not really worked with
quantitative people,
or maybe is wedded to a toolset.
Maybe they use a business
intelligence tool,
and you're advocating
Shiny, and it's interactive,
or something like that.
So to them, there's
some kind of context
which, even if, let's say,
quantitatively there isn't, do
you have any advice on how
to advocate that and get
the buy-in?
And, of course, I imagine it's
probably still a question of,
here's why what
I'm about to tell
you should be
interesting or helpful.
But do you have
anything else that's
come up where you say,
this has really worked,
when I'm trying to
advocate something new?
EMILY RIEDERER:
Yeah, no, I think
that's a great point of
tools versus analyzes,
because tools are so
inherently abstract,
it can make it harder.
But I do think probably
how I'd translate it,
leaders inherently,
I think, care
a lot about the
people on their team--
hopefully from the genuinely
caring perspective,
but at least from like
managing capacity perspective,
like bare minimum.
And I think like leading with
the case, I think, of, I think,
most tools you can also
bring a human dimension
into that story.
Whether it's like-- it's such
a pain point that people have
to-- they're doing this manual
work every single month,
then that's inhibiting both them
doing more interesting projects
and their career
development, but there's
a way to automate this thing.
Or like, hey, three months
ago, we had this error and this
breakdown of this process, and
that's because there aren't--
we don't have good
version control on GitHub.
And I think always,
you can tie it either
to business outcomes
or people outcomes.
But I always, I think, try
to anchor more to, what does
any tool do for you?
And there's a broader
framework that I really
like for thinking
about this called
The Jobs to Be Done framework
that comes from the product
management world.
And essentially,
what that says is
you can think about
a tool as someone
you're hiring to do a job.
And I'm saying it at a
trivially high level.
I think there's more
to the actual theory.
But I've always liked
that kind of framework
for thinking about the
interview-- thinking about,
why should I like bother
to hire and onboard you?
And is this tool more like--
almost going back to
the AI discussion--
is this like an
intern that I only
want to use with a very
high level of supervision,
or, if you're thinking about
CI/CD and process automation,
it's like, am I hiring an
executive or a contractor
to run this process for
me and abstract it way?
And I think that's like--
that framework, I think,
is really, whether it's
implicit or explicit,
hooked to my storytelling around
those technical tools also.
LOUIS BOGUCHWAL:
Very cool, thank you.
Thank you, very helpful.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Thank you.
So I see we have a
few minutes left here,
and I think still quite
a few questions here.
So I'm going to go and try
and go through some of these
quickly.
But I see Bill had asked--
he said, I'm in
pharma but wonder
if there are trends blessed
by management to move away
from some alternative software--
which is how Bill says SaaS.
But maybe more
broadly, are there
trends from your leadership
like moving towards open source?
Or do you have free reign over
the tools that you get to use?
EMILY RIEDERER:
Yeah, so I definitely
feel really lucky to be
in an environment that's
pretty much always been very,
very friendly to open source.
And I think that is--
I know a trend I've seen
across the industry.
I've had the opportunity
also to do some consulting
projects with other people--
more into biostats and pharma
fields, taking that leap to--
I'd copy Bill's very diplomatic
phrasing, if I could,
but other proprietary
options to the R world.
And especially, I mean, I
can only imagine, I think,
the intersection of data tooling
with the current economic
conditions, I have to imagine,
can only accelerate that trend
when it's becoming an
increasingly easy-to-hire skill
set, much more attractive
option for the bottom line.
And I think that
gains that have been
made in adoption in both
banking and finance,
as well as health care,
really put a lot more
of a rubber stamp of
approval on some version
of open source in a really
highly regulated industry.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Thank you.
And Amrit, I see you had a
question about transitioning
into data science roles.
Do you want to jump in here?
AMRIT BHAT: Yeah, thank you.
And hi, Emily.
EMILY RIEDERER: Hey.
AMRIT BHAT: Yeah,
so my basic question
was that I am just transitioning
into data science roles,
or I'm looking for
data science roles.
So I was just wondering,
are there any considerations
I should be having
while interviewing
with companies, and in terms
of maximizing my capacity
to learn in that company?
Because I'll just give
you some more context.
I was just talking to one of
my friends who is in the health
care space, and she was
saying-- she's working as a data
scientist, but then she was
saying that a lot of her time
goes into data processing
rather than actually having to--
being able to get any
inferences out of data
or being able to do any
kind of predictive work.
So yeah, I was just
wondering if there
are any considerations
I should be having,
or if this is a non-question.
I'm really not sure.
EMILY RIEDERER:
Yeah, no, I mean,
I think there are three
aspects, I'd say, to that.
I think first, it definitely can
be really helpful to understand
a company's tech stack
when you're interviewing,
and the amount of data
they have available--
that you don't want to be
hired to be a data scientist,
and then show up on day one and
have them be like, oh, yeah,
here's a Google Drive
with some CSVs in it.
Like, go wild.
I mean, you want to be
sure they have enough data
to support analysis,
and that either you'll
be empowered to have the tools
to build out the data you need
yourself, or maybe they
also have data engineering
or other job functions.
Secondly, I think it's helpful
to be crisp about what you want
to learn and grow on in a role.
Data science can be such a
nebulous job title these days.
I mean, I think some places,
it can mean anything from DI,
experimentation, modeling,
machine learning.
And I think really, just
clarifying your interests,
and then just being able
to articulate them--
companies like do not have
any incentive to hire you
for a role you don't want.
So I think being able to share
what you're looking for really
just helps matchmaking.
But finally, I think it's
also really good to recognize,
you can learn a ton in
pretty much any role.
And I think the spending a lot
of time on data processing,
taking that just as an
example, that is sometimes
the hard part, the complex
part, the part that requires,
actually, a lot of the
data science skill set
of understanding, how do I
shape this data in a way that,
because I do understand the
stats, because I do understand
the algorithm, how do I
structure this problem in a way
that the algorithm can
understand the problem?
And at the end of
the day, I think
it's a funny conceit
that in school, we
spend most of our time
learning hyperparameter
tuning and typing that
model.fit, model.predict.
That often isn't the
hard part or, sometimes,
even the most interesting part.
So I think being open with
that kind of growth mindset of,
whatever job you
end up in, there's
going to be a ton to
learn, but a ton of really
interesting work to be done.
AMRIT BHAT: Got you.
Thank you, sir.
I do understand that it's
more about the company
having a good data culture.
And that way, I
think, you will be
able to have more chances
of maximizing your learning.
EMILY RIEDERER: Yeah, for sure.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: It looks like--
EMILY RIEDERER: That
always matters so much.
AMRIT BHAT: Yeah, thanks.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: It looks like
people had some other tips
in the chat, too.
Like Mike said, a
good question to ask
is maybe, what does a data
scientist do on a typical day?
And Adam, I thought
this was funny.
You said-- a tweet
you saw that said,
when you're interviewing
for data science roles,
ask whether you'll have
IT or data engineers.
If not, congratulations,
you're now both.
[LAUGHS] But--
ADAM AUSTIN: It's too real.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I appreciate
everybody sharing the links
and resources in the chat, too.
I know we just got to
the end of the hour here,
and I'm sorry if we
didn't get to answer
everybody's questions.
We have one minute if there's
any other pressing question,
if somebody wants to
raise their hand here.
Emily, what is the
best way for people
to stay in touch with you?
Is it through your website,
or LinkedIn, or GitHub?
EMILY RIEDERER:
Honestly, I think
wherever people are these days.
I'm still-- like for
now, I'm still on Twitter
and still spending far more
time there than I should.
LinkedIn, GitHub, my website
has my contact information,
same with my email, my
handle on pretty much--
I have the fortune of having
an unusual enough last name
that my handle on
LinkedIn, GitHub, Twitter,
my Gmail, everything,
Emily Riederer or wherever.
So yeah, please, don't
hesitate to get in touch.
I also--
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I just--
EMILY RIEDERER: I love getting
to meet more of the community.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Oh,
sorry, I think my internet
was delayed for a second.
But I just shared your
LinkedIn in the chat as well.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
But if anybody has
Emily's website handy or
blog and wants to share that
thought there, too.
But thank you so much,
Emily, for joining us today
and for sharing your insights
and experience with all of us.
This was awesome.
EMILY RIEDERER: Oh, thank you.
This was a lot of fun.